SO THESE GUESS MESSED UP.
HOW BAD WERE THESE TEXT
MESSAGES?
>> "DO YOU CELEBRATE KWANZA AT
YOUR SCHOOL," ONE OFFICER
TEXTED.
REPLY, "YEAH, WE BURN THE CROSS
ON THE FIELD, THEN WE CELEBRATE
WHITEMAS."
>> IN ANOTHER TEXT, THE N WORD
IS USED TO DESCRIBE BLACK WOMEN.
"THEY SHOULD BE SPAYED."
RESPONSE, "I SAW ONE AN HOUR AGO
WITH FOUR KIDS."
>> Larry: I'D LIKE TO FORMALLY
APOLOGIZE TO THE PRINCIPAL WHO
OBSERVED THAT BLACK PEOPLE WERE
LEAVING AND I IMPLIED THAT HER
COMMENTS WERE RACIST.
THESE (BLEEP)S ARE RACIST.
OKAY?
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
PLEASE ACCEPT MY APOLOGIES.
AND BY THE WAY, FOUR IS NOT THAT
MANY KIDS!
YOU'RE MAD ABOUT A BLACK WOMAN
WITH FOUR CHILDREN, AND YOU HAVE
NOTHING TO SAY ABOUT A WHITE
FAMILY ON TV THAT'S TRYING TO
BREAK THE VAGINAL CANAL WORLD
SPEED RECORD.
NOTHIN'!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
LOOK, LET'S PLAY TWO RACIST
TEXTS AND A LIE.
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU THREE
RACIST TEXTS.
TWO ARE REAL, AND ONE IS A LIE.
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHICH IS
WHICH.
OKAY, WE'VE GOT CROSS BURNING
LOWERS BLOOD PRESSURE -- THAT'S
A WEIRD ONE.
THEN ALL N-WORD'S MUST
(BLEEP)-ING HANG.
THEN (BLEEP)ING N WORD.
ANY GUESSES?
HA, JUST KIDDING!
THOSE ARE ALL REAL.
WHAT A FUN GAME!
(APPLAUSE)
SERIOUSLY, THOUGH --
HEY, IF YOU'RE TIRED OF
GAMES LISTEN TO.
THIS.
>> THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY IS
INVESTIGATING THREE THOUSAND
CASES IN WHICH THE OFFICERS WERE
INVOLVED, CASES THAT COULD BE
TAINTED BY PERCEIVED RACIAL
BIAS.
>> Larry: PERCEIVED RACIAL
BIAS?
I THINK WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
SPAYING BLACK WOMEN, YOU'RE PAST
PERCEIVED. EVEN THE FERGUSON
COPS ARE, LIKE, "WHOA!"
"THAT SOUNDS A LITTLE RACIST."
BUT ONE OF THE COPS CAME FORWARD
AND MOUTH-TEXTED AN APOLOGY.
>> IF I OFFENDED ANYBODY, I'M
SORRY.
I'M TRULY, TRULY SORRY.
HOWEVER --
>> Larry: NO HOWEVER!
NO HOWEVER!
>> HOWEVER, IT'S BANTER AMONGST
FRIENDS.
>> Larry: BANTER AMONGST
FRIENDS?
ARE YOU GUYS WATCHING THE NEWS
AT ALL?
DO YOU KNOW WHAT YEAR IT IS?
I SUSPECT YOU DO BECAUSE YOU'RE
TEXTING.
I MEAN, IF YOU WERE SENDING
TELEGRAMS ABOUT THIS, MAY I'D
GIVE YOU A PASS.
"HOW ABOUT THEM (BLEEP)-ING
APES?
STOP."
"I THINK WE SHOULD BURN A CROSS.
IT WOULD BE WRONG, BUT YOU'RE
OBVIOUSLY STUCK IN A DIFFERENT
TIME.
AND WHAT MAKES IT MORE
TROUBLING -- THIS HAPPENED IN
SAN FRANCISCO, HOME OF
RICE-A-RONI  AND OTHER TOLERANT
PROGRESSIVE STUFF.